the people in your life are allowed to
have their emotional reactions and it's
not your responsibility to manage their
emotional reactions part of the reason
why we get hooked into these toxic
Dynamics with people because you're part
of the dynamic somebody does something
that triggers you you go right in you
start to change how you show up you
start to compensate you start to people
please or you get all mad and angry and
next thing you know it erupts and it's
the same thing over and over and over
again and you wonder why it never
changes well part of the reason why is
that person's never going to change you
cannot control that but you can change
the energy you're putting into the
dynamic